41e jour de la guerre en ukraine les
accusations de crimes de guerre se font
plus fortes notamment après la
découverte de dizaines de corps de
civils abattus à bout de chat en
banlieue de kiev mais pas uniquement les
mystérieux craignant l'intérieur dit
avoir ouvert quelques 1200 enquête pour
crimes de guerre rien que dans la région
de la capitale ont fait le point avec
l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux en ukraine
gulliver crack bonjour gulliver comment
réagissent les ukrainiens à à ces
accusations de crimes de guerre
je pense que le pays est vraiment sous
le choc horrifié par ces accusations par
ces révélations par ces images que les
ukrainiens découvre il est difficile
pour le moment d'évaluer exactement
l'échelle de ces crimes et la nature est
ce que il s'agit le plus souvent de
tueries par balles ou d'autres exactions
ce matin il y a eu des révélations dans
la nuit annoncée par les autorités
régionales dans la région de soumis qui
est au nord de l'ukraine que des
habitants de caunes au top aurait été
selon le gouverneur torturé il y à des
révélations venant d'autres endroits
abuja on parle de dizaines de morts
visiblement tuée par balle ce n'est pas
du tout le seul endroit il y à d'autres
localités où il y a eu des traitements
similaires des ukrainiens des civils par
les russes qui occupaient ces
territoires et maintenant ce sont des
territoires qui sont aux mains des
ukrainiens à nouveau donc il est
difficile d'évaluer l'échelle mais on a
l'impression que la mentalité derrière
est vraiment de l'autre d'une intention
à ces sinistres contre les ukrainiens du
moins celle sentiment je pense que ce
pays a en ce moment puisque au moment
même de ces révélations il y a eu cette
publication dans l' agence de presse
nationale russe ria novosti un article
appelant à la dénazification de
l'ukraine mais qui appelait en réalité
tout simplement à la destruction de
l'ukraine en tant que état il disait
qu'il faudrait aussi une taie ukrainy za
sion et que l'ukraine ne pourrait pas
vraiment existé en tant que tel c'est
selon l'auteur mais c'est je pense de
plus en plus tu craignais commencé à
penser peut-être ce qui était un peu
sceptique qui disait avant que que les
ukrainiens qui disait que poutine veut
vraiment nous détruire il y a quelques
mois vous pourrez tour et beaucoup de
gens en ukraine qui pensaient que ce
genre de rhétorique était exagéré je
pense que maintenant beaucoup beaucoup
de plus d'ukrainiens commencent à
considérer sérieusement la possibilité
que les intentions de vladimir poutine
envers l'ukraine sont réellement
génocidaire le retrait des troupes
russes de certaines régions ne doivent
pas faire oublier qu'une guerre est
toujours en cours qu'il y à des combats
gulliver's et ses combats il se
concentre notamment sur l'est du pays 1
oui d'abord ce qu'on pourrait aussi
souligner c'est que l'autre révélation
de boudhha c'est la défaite cuisante
qu'ont subis les forces russes quand il
quittait la région de kiev on voit j'ai
été avant-hier abuja et on voit
clairement que ce n'était pas un retrait
fait en bon ordre après qu'une mission
avaient été accomplis on voit partout
des chars russes complètement détruit
c'est en quelque sorte une hymne
humiliations des forces russes qui
maintenant comme ils l'ont dit semble se
concentrait effectivement sur l'est de
l'ukraine mais c'est une armée russe a
substantiellement diminué parce que leur
a infligée les ukrainiens pendant la
région de kiev mais probablement
toujours capable d'infliger des
dp pertes sur les ukrainiens dans l'est
de l'ukraine qui est toujours bombardée
et les civils sont toujours touchés
quand il y à ces bombardements il y a
notamment des civils qui ont trouvé la
mort à venise cassé juste au nom de
donetsk pendant la nuit et ce n'est pas
que l'est non plus qui est visé nicolas
yves dans le sud de l'ukraine a subi un
bombardement hier où 10 civils
visiblement on trouvait la mort du livre
craag depuis le centre ouest de
l'ukraine merci beaucoup gulliver